When most people try to get a new job. They
search for a listing. Then they apply. And
then they wait. Search… apply… wait… over
and over again. This is all wrong.
I’ve hired over a hundred people in my career
and today I’m going to explain exactly how
to get a new job in just 3 weeks.
Hunting for a new job can feel daunting
and believe me, I’ve been there, but I
promise you that there is a right way
and a wrong way to go about finding a job.
The method I’m going to outline doesn’t just
apply to finding a job. This works in sales,
operations, and even fundraising. I’ve actually
used this exact technique to raise over
$100 million dollars for my businesses.
If you’re new here, I’m John. I live in
Los Angeles, California and have been
an entrepreneur for the past decade. Every
week I put out new videos about technology
startups so please hit that subscribe button
and ring the bell so you don’t miss any.
Okay, let me walk you through how most people
apply for jobs and then explain why it takes
forever and rarely gets results.
First, you start searching around for
job postings, casually bouncing between websites
until you find something that looks interesting.
You read the post and see if you could qualify.
Usually the job description is extremely long
and vague with dozens of qualifications
that sometimes contradict one another.
Then, after you find something that looks good,
you fill out an application and start to wait. If
you don’t hear back, you start to look for another
job listing, but this is extremely slow.
Then, even after you’ve applied,
you have to wait through several
rounds of phone screens and interviews
to even find out if you got the job.
I see people all the time doing this and it takes
them forever to land a new job. This can be really
dangerous, because, for better or worse, lots of
human resource departments are trained to filter
out candidates with “resume gaps” - meaning that
more than a few months passed between jobs.
Following this process of search -> apply ->
interview is terrible and can lead to a downward
spiral where it actually gets harder the longer
you work at it. But there’s a much better way.
Essentially, instead of doing one
step after another, you want to do
everything in parallel. That means instead
of just searching for a single job posting,
you need to collect hundreds of postings
before you fill out a single application.
Getting a job is just like selling a product,
it’s impossible to have a 100% conversion rate,
so you need to acknowledge that up front. Apple
has one of the best brands in the world, and some
really great marketing to push their products,
but not every Apple advertisement is going to
lead to a customer purchase, so they spread their
bets out and market their products broadly.
Let’s break the entire job hunting
process down into 3 key steps,
which could be done one week at a time.
First up is what I call research and development.
This is what happens before you apply to a single
job posting. This whole process is about being as
efficient as possible, so it’s important to do all
of your research in parallel. Your goal here is
to build a massive list of prospects that you can
reach out to in step 2, so organization is key.
Instead of searching for job postings in this
stage, you need to search for companies and,
more specifically, individual people
who have the authority to hire you.
Start by listing out every company that operates
in whatever industry you were just working in.
Then expand out based on your specific skill
set. So if you’ve been working in marketing
at an electronics company, start by finding
as many electronics companies as possible,
then broadening out to any company with
a growing marketing department.
Don’t try and filter too much at
this stage, instead just focus on
gathering as much information as possible
and compiling everything in a spreadsheet.
If you’re used to using a tool like Notion
or Airtable, you can definitely use those,
but Google Sheets is fine too. Just make sure to
note the companies name and how big they are.
Working for a small company can be dramatically
different than working for a large corporation,
so it’s worthwhile to keep size in
mind. You can usually find out how
many employees a particular company has
by searching LinkedIn or just Google.
Applying for jobs is really a sales process,
and not every lead is going to convert into a
job offer, so you want to maximize your
“top of funnel” leads by collecting as
many potential opportunities as possible.
It’s not crazy to compile a list of over a hundred
potential companies before you start applying.
If you spend 5 minutes researching each company,
you should be able to compile a list
of 100 companies in just one day.
Once you have these companies listed out, start
developing your leads. This is where you start
to find job listings and contact information
for managers who hire people with your skills.
You should be adding information to each row in
your spreadsheet so you wind up with names and
contact information for every target company.
This is also a good time to start developing your
personal elevator pitch. As you research
these companies and start seeing patterns
in what they are hiring for, try to imagine
how you would fit into the organization. There
is often a big mismatch between the title
of the job and the description below.
At Google, a software engineer might be
expected to have a computer science degree
and really understand algorithms, whereas a small
company outside the tech industry might still be
hiring a software engineer, but just need someone
who can build a simple website. You want to figure
out what skills you have and what skills are
immediately adjacent to your experience.
If you feel like you’re lacking a specific skill,
now is a great opportunity to go and learn more.
If you’ve been programming for a few years, but
don’t really have any experience with design,
take time before your job search fully gets going
to try and get up to speed with the basics of that
discipline. You can’t become an expert, but
it never hurts to be more well rounded.
Then comes step 2: Parallel Outreach.
This is really the heart of this entire process.
HR departments are notoriously slow to process
job applications and you never want to be in a
position where you’re waiting to hear back
about a job and have nothing to do.
In a great scenario, maybe 10% of job
applications are going to turn into interviews,
so you really need to fill up your leads
spreadsheet before you start reaching out.
The goal is to only go through this process once,
and then just decide between multiple job offers
at the end, but you can obviously repeat the
cycle if need be. The key is to keep the top
of the funnel as big as possible so every
stage has the maximum chance of converting.
Applying to multiple jobs can be really
daunting and it’s not uncommon to think
you should focus all your energy on a single
posting and spend an entire week preparing
for that, but that’s a huge mistake.
The first stage of any hiring process is
basically just a filter. You might be the
perfect candidate for a position, and spend
weeks preparing an amazing application, only
to find out that they hired someone a week ago
and just forgot to close out the job listing.
So, you need to standardize your process for
applying. You don’t want to spam people, but
a little bit of process optimization can go a
long way here. After all, if you’re serious
about applying to a hundred jobs in one go,
you can’t spend much time on each one. So, you
need to create a workflow for efficiency.
You can use a tool like MailMerge to automatically
fill out personalized emails, but sometimes this
can backfire. Even if you add personal details
like the name of the person you’re emailing,
it can still feel like a marketing email,
where there were clearly just a few holes
that got filled in automatically.
Instead, you should have a few lines
of boilerplate about yourself, and then
customize the rest. In your spreadsheet,
you should have the name of the company and
the name of the person you’re reaching out to,
which is a good starting point.
If you have time, be sure to add in
a few details about the position and why you
want to work for the company. This is a great
place to show that you did some research and
mention a recent announcement by the company
that you couldn’t have possibly autofilled.
The key here is to stick to a schedule. If your
target is to apply to a hundred companies
in a single week, you shouldn’t spend more
than 25 minutes per company. That should
be plenty of time if you’re well organized
and have all your supporting materials
like a resume and links to relevant work
experience all together in one place.
As you’re applying, really try and figure
out what steps you have to repeat over
and over again so you can automate them.
Tools like AutoHotKey and TextExpander can create
macros to keep you from typing the same sentence
over and over again. Regardless of whether you use
Mac or PC, there are great options to help speed
up your process and I’ll leave some links to
helpful resources right below the like button.
Step 3 is what I called targeted interviewing.
It’s easy to treat every interview the same way
and put your maximum effort into one, but that’s
actually a common error. Interviewing for a new
job should be as much about you deciding whether
or not you want the job as the company decided
whether or not they want to hire you.
Job postings can be very misleading,
and that’s not always the companies fault. The
hiring manager could be using an old template,
or the company's goals could have shifted
since they put up the job req.
Either way, you can’t fall into the trap of
thinking you have to see every interview process
to the end. Far too many managers would love to
hire someone who’s a bit overqualified, and you
don’t want to end up being that someone.
It’s important to validate early on in the
interview process exactly what you will be
doing and assess whether that’s a fit for you.
You might have done a particular job a few
years ago and hated it, so even though you’re
technically qualified, you need to filter out any
companies that want you to do that old job.
There are two added benefits to
this more aggressive approach.
First, taking an active interest in the position
and really digging in to see if it’s what you want
to be doing for the next few years shows a lot of
initiative, and that looks good in interviews.
Second, declining to advance to the next round
after a phone screen reveals that a job isn’t
quite right for you builds your confidence. If you
followed the first two steps properly, you should
have plenty of interviews going on simultaneously
and never feel like you have to take a job because
it’s the only opportunity available.
This strategy is all about parallelism and
if you do it right, you’ll wind up in a great
situation where you can actually decide between
multiple job offers and weigh the pros and cons
of each. You might even be able to negotiate
for a higher salary at the most interesting
company because you have some real leverage.
Even though human resources are legally limited
in what they can ask you about your job search,
most managers can sense when a
candidate they really want to hire
has multiple offers, even if you don’t say it
explicitly. So use this to your advantage.
If you’d like to go a bit deeper, please
drop your email at johncoogan.com,
and please check out this recommended video, the
YouTube algorithm thinks you’ll really like it.